This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2011, Richard Freeman was studying scientists, specifically how scientists walk together. Richard, who's a Harvard economics professor, noticed something surprising. Scientists in the United States stick to their own kind. You'd see Chinese folk concentrated in one lab, Indian folk concentrated in another lab, Europeans of different groups, associating more with their compatriots. This was not surprising. You see this kind of clustering in lots of workplaces.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。2011年，理查德·弗里曼一直在研究科学家，特别是科学家是如何结伴而行的。理查德是一名哈佛大学经济学教授，他注意到了一件令人惊讶的事。美国的科学家只和自己人呆在一起。你会看到中国人在一个实验室里扎堆，印度人在另一个实验室扎堆，来自不同群体的欧洲人也更多地与同胞交往。这并不令人意外。你在许多工作场所都能看到这种抱团现象。
But Richard thought, science ought to be different. It general people who are more alike are likely to think more alike and one of the things that gives a kick to science and scientific productivity is that you get people with somewhat different views, different perspectives coming together. Some people agree with Richard's contention that a mix of perspectives will produce better ideas. But others say, no, a group that has lots of different views will end up in gridlock. So, which is it? Richard decided to figure out whether scientists who collaborate with others from the same group
但理查德认为，科学理应有所不同。一般而言，越是相似的人往往思维也越相似，而推动科学发展和科研生产力的因素之一，正是让那些观点和视角有所不同的人走到一起来。有些人同意理查德的观点，即多元的视角会产生更好的想法。但另一些人则认为，并非如此，一个有着大量不同观点的群体最终会陷入僵局。那么，到底是哪一种呢？理查德决定弄清楚，那些与来自同一群体的其他人进行合作的科学家，
produce better or worse research than scientists who have a wide network of collaborators. He looked at one of the most important signals of scientific success, research publications. He found that in a large share of these scientific publications, co-authors shared a common ethnicity. No surprise. But then he went further. He looked at citations. In general, the better a paper, the more likely it is to be cited by researchers writing other papers. We asked, well, are the papers done by people who are more ethnically the same? Are those papers, do they get more attention?
其产出的研究成果是更好还是更糟，是与那些拥有广泛合作者网络的科学家相比而言。他考察了科学成功最重要的标志之一：研究论文。他发现，在很大程度上，这些科研论文的共同作者都具有相同的族裔背景。这并不奇怪。但接着他进行了更深入的研究。他考察了引用率。一般来说，一篇论文越好，就越有可能被撰写其他论文的研究人员引用。我们不禁要问，那么，由族裔背景更相同的人完成的论文呢？这些论文获得的关注度会更高吗？
Do they have more citations? Do they appear in journals that are of greater prestige? The answer was no. Papers that got the most citations, the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world.
它们的被引次数更多吗？它们会发表在声望更高的期刊上吗？答案是否定的。被引用次数最多、世界上最负盛名的论文……（译者注：此处音频或转写存在重复冗余，按原文原样翻译）世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。
People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world.
世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。
People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the world. People are the most prestigious citizens of the US, between countries rather than people only working in the same group. The finding held true, no matter which ethnic groups you looked at. And I think the key thing is to get more ideas linked together so they can spawn better ideas,
世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。世界上最负盛名的公民们。美国公民，跨越国界合作而非仅仅在同一群体中工作的人。这一发现在你考察哪个族裔群体时都成立。我认为关键在于把更多的想法联系在一起，这样它们就能催生出更好的想法，
as opposed to working in the same way. We're going to ask a question today that draws on Richard's finding and scientific research. What happens when people put themselves in contact with difference, with people whose ideas and history differ from their own. Diversity, conflict and creativity. This week on Hidden Brain. In the far northwest of Spain is a place of farms and forests and ocean. Galithia. It's a region of rugged coastlines, hardy stews, and the Galithian backpipe. I come from Orense, which is one of the four provinces of Galicia.
而不是以同样的方式工作。今天我们要探讨一个借鉴了理查德的研究成果和科学研究的问题。当人们让自己接触到差异——接触到那些思想和历史与自己不同的人时，会发生什么？多元、冲突与创造力。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在西班牙的最西北部，有一个充满农田、森林和海洋的地方。加利西亚。这是一个拥有崎岖海岸线、丰盛炖菜和加利西亚风笛的地区。我来自奥伦塞，它是加利西亚的四个省份之一。
This is Christina Pato, she's a backpack player. When you grew up in Galicia, you grew up hearing music everywhere, hearing music in Abar, hearing music in Asquare, celebrating the festivities of the day or wedding weddings or in even birthdays. I mean, when you are in Galicia, you pretty much can hear the backpipes almost everywhere. Christina has been playing the backpipes since she was a child. She grew up in a musical household. Her father was an accordion player.
这是克里斯蒂娜·帕托，她是一名风笛手。当你成长于加利西亚时，你到处都能听到音乐，在酒吧里听到音乐，在广场上听到音乐，在庆祝节日、婚礼甚至生日时都能听到音乐。我的意思是，当你身处加利西亚时，几乎到处都能听到风笛声。克里斯蒂娜从小就开始吹奏风笛。她在一个音乐世家中长大。她的父亲是一名手风琴手。
Her three older sisters all played the backpipes. She started playing when she was four. By the time she was ten, Christina and her sister Raquel would travel to villages to play at festivals. In those streets, the sound of two backpipes at 8am is something that everybody can not only hear but also recognize. My sister and I will be just waiting for them to come out, play a little Muneera which is the Galician National Dance and people will just start dancing around. As she grew older, Christina began to experiment with her
她的三个姐姐都会吹风笛。她四岁时就开始演奏了。到十岁时，克里斯蒂娜和她的姐姐拉克尔就会去各个村庄的节日上演出。在那些街道上，早晨八点两支风笛的声音不仅是每个人都能听到，而且也是每个人都能认出来的。我和我姐姐会在那里等着它们出来，演奏一曲加利西亚民间舞蹈——穆涅拉（Muneera），人们就会开始围着跳舞。随着年龄的增长，克里斯蒂娜开始尝试用她的
bat pipes. She started to play music that wasn't embedded in the folkloric As she grew older, Christina began to experiment with her backpipes. She started to play music that wasn't embedded in the folkloric tradition. She started touring with bands. At 18, she released her first solo album. The more Christina's stretched, the better she got. By the time her second album was released two years later, she died her hair bright green and acquired a nickname, the Jimmy Galicia, the backpipes remained deeply embedded in tradition. But improvisation came naturally to her. She needed to make her own kind of music. I was trying to just tell people this is what I am and I is not like I don't care about what you think about what I do with my instrument,
风笛进行创新。她开始演奏那些并非植根于民俗……随着年龄的增长，克里斯蒂娜开始尝试用她的风笛进行创新。她开始演奏那些并非植根于民俗传统音乐。她开始随乐队巡演。18岁时，她发行了自己的第一张个人专辑。克里斯蒂娜的尝试越多，她的技艺就越精湛。两年后她的第二张专辑发行时，她把头发染成了亮绿色，并获得了一个绰号：“加利西亚的吉米（Jimi）”。风笛依然深深植根于传统之中。但即兴演奏对她来说是自然而然的事。她需要创作属于自己的音乐。我只是想告诉人们，这就是我，并不是说我不在乎你如何看待我用乐器做的事，
but there is something about what I do with my instrument that keeps me going. By the time she was a young adult, Christina had to make a choice. It seemed to her like the backpipes could only take her so far. Christina had also been trained in classical piano. In her mid-twenties, she decided to leave Spain and go to the United States. She would pursue a mainstream musical career with a piano. And I moved here. I didn't tell anybody around me when I went to Rackers University to get my doctorate, but I had another life. Christina kept her two lives separate.
而是我对乐器所做的一些事情支撑着我不断前行。到了青年时期，克里斯蒂娜不得不做出选择。在她看来，风笛似乎只能带她走到这一步了。克里斯蒂娜还接受过古典钢琴的正规训练。二十多岁时，她决定离开西班牙前往美国。她将用钢琴追求主流的音乐职业生涯。于是我搬到了这里。当我前往罗格斯大学攻读博士学位时，我没有告诉身边的任何人，但我过着另一种生活。克里斯蒂娜把她的两重生活分得很开。
One side of her was a diligent classical music student. The other was still a green-haired backpipe player from Galicia. One day, in her second semester, a professor asked for help in translating a song. So I get this call from the professor of the vocal department, and she says, I have a son in here, which is in a language that I believe is closer to Spanish. So I was wondering if you could be the pianist for this singer
她的一面是一个勤奋的古典音乐学生。另一面依然是那个来自加利西亚、留着绿发的风笛手。有一天，在她的第二个学期，一位教授请求她帮忙翻译一首歌曲。于是我接到了声乐系教授的电话，她说：“我这里有一首歌，它的语言据我所知接近西班牙语。所以我想知道你是否能担任这位歌手的钢琴伴奏，
and also the coach, the vocal coach for diction. And when I see this car, it was Lua de Escalorida, which is literally colorless moon in Galithian. And this was a poem by the most amazing Galithian poet of all times Rosalia de Castro, a female writer of the end of the 19th century. And this composer who, to be honest honest I didn't know anything about him. This composer actually has chosen that poem to create music around it. That composer it turns out was celebrated. An Argentinian named Oswald Ogolyhoff.
同时担任咬字发音的声乐教练。”当我看到这张谱子时，它是《月亮之色》（Lua de Escalorida），在加利西亚语中字面意思是无色之月。这是一首由有史以来最了不起的加利西亚诗人罗莎莉亚·德·卡斯特罗（Rosalia de Castro）创作的诗，她是一位19世纪末的女作家。而这位作曲家——说实话，我对他一无所知——这位作曲家实际上选择了那首诗来为之谱曲。这位作曲家后来证明是一位著名的音乐家。一个名叫奥斯瓦尔多·戈利霍夫（Oswaldo Golijov）的阿根廷人。
She met him at rehearsal. We started talking about Alicia. Then he got excited. Then I told him, well, I actually pray the other, the other most important thing about Galicia and which is Negalicia's backpipe. And then his eyes opened even wider. Fast forward six months, Christina got a call. It was uswoldo. He says, why don't you and your husband come to Lenox as a chosen some year with some
她在排练时遇到了他。我们开始聊起加利西亚。然后他兴奋起来。接着我告诉他，其实我还演奏另一种乐器，加利西亚最重要的事情之一，也就是加利西亚的风笛。然后他的眼睛睁得更大了。快进六个月，克里斯蒂娜接到一个电话。是奥斯瓦尔多打来的。他说：“你和你丈夫为什么不来莱诺克斯参加一个夏令营，带上一些朋友，带上你的风笛，是的，就来和我们一起玩得开心点吧。”于是他们去了。我们见到奥斯瓦尔多，开始交谈，他说：“今晚我们有个聚会，我希望你能向大家展示你的乐器，稍微讲讲你的传统、你的音乐、你所做的事情，我确信他们会喜欢它的。”所以我就那样做了，和一群陌生人一起用我的乐器演奏，而在场的人里我唯一能肉眼认出的，只有小马（Jojo）。
friends, being your back-by, and yeah, just come and have fun with us. So they went. We see uswoldo, we started talking and he says, well tonight we are having like gathering and I was hoping for you just to show them your instrument, talk a little bit about your tradition, your music, what you do and I'm sure they will love it. So there I was, like playing my instrument with a bunch of strangers that I, the only person I could recognize physically, it was Jojo.
小马？小马，小马，马友友，大提琴手。世界上最声名显赫、最著名的大提琴手。克里斯蒂娜没有意识到的是，她误打误撞走进了一个挤满来自世界各地的音乐大师的房间。他们是马友友创建的一个团体的一部分。这是一个被称为“丝绸之路合奏团”的集体，它汇聚了来自世界各地的音乐家。他们是马友友创建的一个团体的一部分。这是一个被称为“丝绸之路合奏团”的集体，它汇聚了来自不同文化和不同传统的音乐家。
Jojo? Jojo, Jojo, Ma, the cellist. The most renowned and famous cellist in the world. What Christina didn't realize was that she'd stumbled into a room filled with master musicians from around the world. They were part of a group created by Jojo Ma. It's a collective known as the Silk Road ensemble, and it brings together musicians from around the world. They were part of a group created by Yo-Yo Ma. It's a collective known as the Silk Road ensemble, and it brings together musicians from different cultures and different traditions.
我很幸运，那天晚上我甚至不知道我在为谁演奏，因为如果我知道的话，我可能就不会那么自由地去想：这些人是谁？我在他们所有人面前做什么？我开始演奏，他们开始提问，我兴奋起来，然后我邀请他们加入进来一起演奏，结果那天晚上，我们所有人都跳起了一支加利西亚穆涅拉舞，我还教他们怎么跳，
I kind of was lucky that that night I didn't even know who I was playing for because if I did, probably would not have felt so free in the idea of, what are these people, what am I doing in front of all of them? I began playing, they started asking questions, I got excited, then I asked them to join and play, and then we ended up that evening, all dancing a Galiheen Muneera that I coached them, how to dance it,
那一刻在所有可能的方向上真正改变了我的人生。而在那一刻，我甚至没有意识到那一刻对我的余生意味着什么。这是一个转折点。克里斯蒂娜加入了丝绸之路合奏团。她拥抱了该集体的愿景，一个始于一个简单问题的愿景。当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？这就是马友友提出的问题。
and that moment really changed my life in every possible direction. And in that moment I didn't even realize how much that moment was going to mean for the rest of my life. It was a turning point. Christina joined the Silk Road ensemble. She embraced the vision for the collective, a vision that began with a simple question. What could happen when a stranger's meet? What could happen when strangers meet? This is the question you're your maharast.
来自许多不同文化的音乐家聚集在一起时能创造出什么？事实证明，是一些极其美好的东西。马友友将这个集体的工作描述为他所谓的“边缘效应”。克里斯蒂娜说这是一个深深触动她的理念。边缘效应是指两个生态系统相遇的交界点，比如森林和草原，显然在生态学中，正是在这个边缘效应中，最多的新生命形式
What could musicians from many different cultures create when they come together? It turns out something extraordinarily beautiful. Jojo Ma describes the work of the collective as something he calls the Edge Effect. Christina says it's an idea that stuck with her. The Edge Effect is the pointing which two ecosystems meet, like the forest and the savannah, and apparently in ecology, in this Edge Effect is where the most new life forms
被创造出来。某种程度上，“丝绸之路”就是他对这种边缘效应的一种重现。对克里斯蒂娜来说，在那个新生命形式涌现的地带工作，改变了她看待音乐的方式。她开始质疑为什么身为主播的克里斯蒂娜和身为古典钢琴家的克里斯蒂娜，必须生活在不同的世界里。确实，音乐是不同的，传统是不同的，甚至连观众看起来也
are created. And somehow Silk Road is some sort of his recreation of this edge effect. For Christina, working in that zone where new life forms emerge, that changed the way she saw music. She began to question why Christina, the backpipe player and Christina, the classical pianist, had to live in different worlds. It's true, the music was different, the traditions were different, even the audiences seemed
不同。但这又怎样呢？突然之间，通过与丝绸之路合作，我找到了我一生所生活的两个世界之间的联系，而在我的家乡，这两个世界甚至是没有关联的。你还必须明白，在我出身的奥伦塞，风笛学校和古典音乐音乐学院是两栋毗邻的建筑。在一个拥有十万人口的城市里，这所风笛学校有超过一万人以某种方式与它有关联。而我用一只手的指头就能数过来，
different. But so what? All of a sudden, working with Silrod, I found the connections between the two worlds I've been living on my life that were not even connected in my hometown. And you have to understand also that in Orénse where I come from, the Backpipers School and the Conservatory for Classical Music were two buildings next to each other. This Backpipers School had, in a city of 100,000 people, had more than 10,000 somehow involved with the Backpiper School. And I could count with the fingers of my hands,
那些既能去上课、接受古典音乐训练，同时又接受过风笛训练的人。克里斯蒂娜说，吸引她的是不同音乐形式之间建立联系和对话的可能性。克里斯蒂娜说，吸引她的是不同音乐形式之间建立联系和对话的可能性。在丝绸之路，你还必须不断前行，去结识新的陌生人，结识新的社群，结识那些你从未想象过与之合作的人群。也许把那些你绝不会认为能组合在一起的乐器融合起来，
the people that could actually go to both, to go training classical music, but also got trained as a Backpiper. Christina says that what drew her was the possibility for connections and conversations between different musical forms. says that what drew her was the possibility for connections and conversations between different musical forms. In Silver Road, you also have to keep going in meeting new strangers, meeting new communities, meeting communities of people that you have never imagined of working with. And maybe putting together instruments that you will never think they will work together
比如加利西亚风笛和日本尺八。在某种程度上，对我而言，“丝绸之路”是21世纪社会的隐喻，或者至少寄托了我对21世纪社会的期许。丝绸之路的音乐家们在音乐中发现了理查德·弗里曼在科学中发现的东西。有趣的事情发生在来自不同群体的人们走到一起、共同工作、发生碰撞的时候。群体走到一起、共同工作、发生碰撞的时候。稍后回来，我们将探讨解释为什么多元化和创造力往往密不可分的科学研究。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。嗨，亚当，我是香卡。
like a Galician backpackanna Japanese Sakohachi. Somehow to me, Silver Road is the metaphor of the 21st century society or at least to the wish I have for the 21st century society. The Silk Road musicians have discovered in music what Richard Freeman discovered in science. The interesting stuff happens when people from different groups come together, work together, collide. groups come together, work together, collide. When we come back, we look at research that explains why diversity and creativity often go hand in hand. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Hi Adam, I'm Shankar.
很高兴见到你。不久前我在纽约时，顺道拜访了社会心理学家亚当·吉林斯基（Adam Galinsky）的公寓。当制作人珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和我到达那里时，亚当和他的家人们正等在前门迎接我们。亚当与他的妻子珍·奥利恩（Jen O'Lion）、两个年幼的儿子阿舍尔（Asher）和艾丹（Aiden），以及他的岳母维基·奥利恩（Vicki O'Line）一起生活。当我们走进公寓时，亚当提出了一个小小的请求。
Nice to meet you. Not long ago when I was in New York, I stopped by the apartment of social psychologist Adam Gylinski. When reproducer Jenny Schmidt and I got there, Adam and his family were waiting for us at the front door. Adam lives with his wife, Jen O'Lion, his two young sons, Asher and Aiden, and his mother and son, Vicki O'Line. As we walked into the apartment, Adam made a quick request.
我们脱下了靴子，亚当和珍指了指放在长凳下方的一排室内鞋。如果你喜欢的话，这里有一些防滑拖鞋。亚当承认，在家里不穿鞋并不是他成长过程中养身习惯的一部分。在跟珍约会之前，我从来没在自己家里脱过鞋。珍甚至不允许我们穿着外面的衣服坐在床上。所以我真的把这个习惯融入了生活中。我现在去酒店，在坐在床上之前都会先把裤子脱掉。珍对于把家的内部与外部世界隔离开有着强烈的观念。
We slipped off our boots and Adam and Jen pointed to a selection of house shoes they kept under a bench. Here's some slip-wise if you like. Adam admits that having a shoe-free house wasn't something he'd done growing up. I'd never taken my shoes off in my own house before dating Jen. Jen even doesn't want us to put our clothes on, outside clothes on, sitting on the bed. So I really integrate this. I go to hotels now and I take off my pants before sitting on the bed. Jen has strong ideas about keeping the inside of a home separate from the outside world.
随着时间的推移，亚当已经把这些观念内化为自己的了。我认为这确实让我以一种完全不同的方式思考空间，以及人们如何构建他们的世界和室内环境。现在我家里的室内设计比我单身时好得多。亚当在北卡罗来纳州的一个世俗犹太家庭中长大。珍在康涅狄格州长大，她的父母是从菲律宾移民过来的。他们一直保留着菲律宾文化。这种文化的一部分包括对家庭的深深尊重，这种尊重也被珍继承了下来。
Over time, Adam has made those ideas his own. I think that that's really made me think about space in a totally different way and how people construct their worlds and their interior environments. And I have much better interior design now in my house than I ever had when I was single. Adam grew up in a secular Jewish family in North Carolina. Jen grew up in Connecticut with parents who were demigrated from the Philippines. They'd held on to their Filipino culture. Part of that culture includes a deep respect for the home or respect they passed on to Jen.
珍反过来又将这种文化信仰传递给了亚当。我认为，是的，现在卧室感觉确实更像一个圣殿了，你知道的，就好像你正跨过这道门槛进入这个不同的传送门一样。珍也吸收了亚当的一些价值观。亚当通过他的犹太传统教会了我去拥抱、敞开心扉去感受，这样一来，在给情绪贴标签和识别情绪时，我往往会把那些事情静音，或者不喜欢真正的冲突，
Jen in turn passed on that cultural belief to Adam. I think that yeah the bedroom now is like it does feel a little bit more like a sanctuary like then you know like it's almost like you're stepping across this into this different portal if you will. Jen is also adopted some of Adam's values. Adam has taught me through his Jewish tradition about embracing opening up a feeling, so that labeling, identifying feelings, I tend to mute those things or don't like real conflict,
所以我总是会避开它。现在，你可能会问，这有什么大不了的？任何一对情侣走到一起，他们都会融合彼此的生活，接受一些东西，放下另一些。但不同之处在于：当来自不同国家或文化的人们走到一起时，它似乎会影响他们的创造力。亚当研究过这个课题，当珍和孩子们不在场时，我们进行了更深入的交谈。
so I'll steer on to it. Now, you might be asking, what's the big deal? Any time a couple gets together, they blend their lives, embrace some things, let go of others. But here's the difference. When people from different countries or cultures come together, it seems to affect their creativity. Adam has studied this topic, we caught up for a longer chat when Jen and the kids weren't around.
我想知道他是如何对多元化和创造力之间的联系产生兴趣的。亚当说这要追溯到很久以前他上高中的时候。在去海外交换一个学期之前，他参加了一个强制性的迎新会。直到今天我还记得，他们说：“听着，你们有些人要去中国，在中国，盘子里留剩饭是一种尊敬的标志，因为这说明你们吃饱了。但在我要去的印度尼西亚，盘子里留剩饭却是不尊敬的标志，因为这基本上说明饭菜不太好吃。”
I wanted to know how he'd gotten interested in the link between diversity and creativity. Adam says it started long ago when he was in high school. Before leaving for a semester abroad, he'd attended a mandatory orientation. And I still remember to this day, they said, look, some of you are going to go to China, and in China, it is a sign of respect if you leave food on your plate because it says that you got enough to eat. But in Indonesia where I was going it's a sign of disrespect to leave food on your plate because it basically says the food wasn't very good.
所以这对我来说是一次开阔眼界、具有变革意义的经历，让我认识到同一个物体——盘子里的食物——根据文化的不同，可以有非常不同的含义和非常相同的影响。相同的事物根据你的背景和视角会有不同的含义。这让亚当好奇，不同的文化如何能帮助我们以不同的方式看待世界，并激发创造力和创新。多年后，他决定在一个研究项目中探索这些想法。整个项目是一个极好的故事，因为它既是科学发现的一个好例子，
And so that was sort of eye-opening, transformational experience for me to recognize the same object, food on a plate, could have very different meanings and have very different implications depending on the culture. The same thing means different things, depending on your background and perspective. It made Adam wonder how different cultures can help us see the world differently and spark creativity and innovation. Years later, he decided to explore these ideas in a research project. The whole project is a great story because it's a good example of both scientific discovery
也是科学合作的一个好例子。亚当和一些同事追踪了一所商学院的一群学生。研究人员假设，在学业结束时表现出最高创造力的学生，也将是那些与来自不同国家的人有最多互动的人。学业结束时表现出最高创造力的人，也将是那些与来自不同国家的人有最多互动的人。收集了大量的数据并对其进行了处理后得出了结果。他们正准备发表，结果另一组研究人员的设计实际上比我们的还要好，
and scientific collaboration. Adam and some colleagues tracked a group of students at a business school. The researchers hypothesized that the students who showed the most creativity at the end of their school years would also be those who had the most interactions with people from different countries. school years would also be those who had the most interactions with people from different countries. The collective vast amount of data crunched the results. They were about to publish when another group of researchers had actually even a better design
抢先一步发表了我们的想法和论文。本该就此结束了。他们的目标一直是发表论文，结果却被人抢先了。因此，尽管他们拥有大量数据，他们还是把数据全部收起来，继续前进了。几年后，我有一名一年级的博士生杰克逊·刘（Jackson Lew），我对他说：“嘿，我们有这些旧数据，我们无法在顶级期刊上发表，因为已经有人抢先发表了，但我们可以把它作为一项重复性研究发表。你为什么不看看这些数据呢？”
than we did and scooped our idea and published the paper. That should have been the end of it. Their goal had been to publish and they'd gotten beat. So even though they had a lot of data, they put it all away and moved on. A couple years later, I had a first-year doctoral student in Jackson-Lew and I said, hey, we have this old data, we can't publish in a great journal because someone already scooped us on it, but we could publish it as a replication simmer good. Why don't you go through the data?
接下来发生的事情，或许就是理查德·弗里曼注意到的那种现象的一个例子：科研项目拥有不同族裔的科学家会有所帮助。杰克逊·刘在亚当的数据中发现了一些令人兴奋的东西，而亚当自己却忽略了这一点。我说：“是什么？”他说：“我发现了这样一个发现：与另一种文化背景的人约会过的人，在商学院生涯中变得更有创造力了，而那些只是拥有异国朋友的人，似乎并没有变得更有创造力。”
What happened next might be an example of the phenomenon Richard Freeman noticed that it helps a research project to have scientists from different ethnicities. Jackson Lewis saw something exciting in Adam's data that Adam himself had overlooked. And I said, what's that? And he said, I found this finding that people who had dated someone from another culture became more creative during their business school career, but those who just had friends from another culture didn't seem to become more creative.
所以，跨文化和浪漫关系有着独特而美妙的地方。杰克逊的热情让亚当和他的同事们眼前一亮。他们意识到自己可能偶然发现了一些重要的事情。为什么与另一种文化的人约会会激发创造力？为什么泛泛的交友就不会有同样的效果呢？于是我们重新开始思考这个概念：这些跨文化联系的深度和亲密程度可能会带来不同。他们设计了一个实验来检验这个发现是否真实。这一次，他们只联系了那些既与不同国家的人约过会、
So there's something unique and wonderful about intercultural and romantic relationships. Jackson's enthusiasm made Adam and his colleagues sit up. They realized they may have stumbled on something important. Why would dating someone from another culture spur creativity? Why would casual friendships not work the same way? So we started thinking again about this idea of a deep or the depth and the closeness of those intercultural connections might make a difference. The designed an experiment to test whether the finding was real. This time they reached out only to students who had both dated someone from a different
也与自己国家的人约过会的学生。然后，这些学生被随机分成两组。在其中一种情况下，我们要求他们回忆他们与自己文化背景的人约会的经历，并描述那段经历。而在另一种情况下，我们说：回忆一下你与另一种文化背景的人交往的经历。那段经历是怎样的？之后，研究人员要求学生反思他们对自己文化和其他文化了解了多少。然后他们接受了一项创造力测试。
country and dated someone from their own country. The students were then randomly split into two groups. In one condition, we'll ask them to recall their experience they had with their dating someone from their own culture and just describe that experience. Now in the other condition, we said, we're called a time when you dated about your one of your relationships someone from another culture. What was that experience like? Afterwards, the researchers asked the students to reflect on how much they learned about their own and the other culture. And then they were given a test for creativity.
如果跨文化浪漫与创造力之间没有联系，那么要求学生反思不同类型的交往应该不会产生任何差异。但研究人员发现的情况并非如此。我们发现，仅仅通过反思跨文化关系，暂时的创造力就会得到提升，而这主要是因为人们觉得他们对另一种文化了解更多，这种文化学习、这种反思和文化学习带来了创造力的提升。塔夫茨大学（Tafts University）的心理学研究也发现了类似的结果。当你将种族多样性引入一个群体时，群体中的所有人都会开始拓宽思维视野，
If there was no connection between intercultural romance and creativity, asking the students to reflect on different kinds of encounters should have made no difference. But that's not what the researchers found. We found that there was a boost in temporary creativity just by reflecting on the intercultural relationship, and that was really driven by the fact that people felt that they had learned more about another culture, and that sort of cultural learning that reflection and that cultural learning led to increased creativity. Psychology research out of Tafts University has found something similar. When you introduce racial diversity into a group, all the people in the group begin to broaden the scope of
去探索更多的选择。现在，创造力可能很难衡量，但科学家们已经设计出了这样做的方。通常，他们会分析他们所谓的分散思维和集中思维。而集中创造力，测试的是那些只有一个正确答案的问题。只有一个正确答案的最著名例子之一就是邓克蜡烛问题（Dunker Candle problem）。在邓克蜡烛问题中，你要求人们——你给他们一支蜡烛、一盒图钉和一盒火柴。然后你告诉他们：把蜡烛固定在墙上，使得蜡烛点燃时，烛油不会滴到墙壁、桌子或地板上。亚当说，当他让普林斯顿大学的一群聪明本科生做这个实验时，只有
their thinking and to explore more options. Now, creativity can be difficult to measure, but scientists have devised ways of doing it. Typically, they analyze what they call divergent thinking and convergent thinking. And convergent creativity, taster ones in which there's a single right answer. And one of the most famous examples of a single right answer is the Dunker Candle problem. And the Dunker Candle problem, you ask people to, you give them a candle, a box of tax, and a book of matches. And you tell them, fix the candle to a wall in such way that the candle when lit doesn't rip wax onto the wall, table, or floor. Adam says that when he tried this with a group of smart, undergraduate Princeton, only a
极小比例的学生在15分钟内看出了问题所在。原因在于，这个测试要求你以一种新的方式思考熟悉的事物。一盒图钉可以用来存放图钉，但也可以当成支架。而解决方案是：你把盒子里的所有图钉倒出来，用图钉把盒子固定在墙上，然后把蜡烛放进盒子里。分散性任务不要求唯一的正确答案。它们要求你产生许多不同的想法。在我们的研究中，我们在第一阶段——当我们首次测量他们的创造力时，
small percentage of the students saw the problem within 15 minutes. The reason is that the test requires you to think about familiar objects in a new way. A box of tax can be a repository for tax, but can also be a stand. And the solution is you dump out all the tax out of the box, you tack the box to the wall, and then you put the candle inside. Divergent tasks don't ask for a single right answer. They require you to produce lots of different ideas. In our study, we ask people at time one, when we first measure their creativity,
要求他们为一块砖头尽可能多地想出创造性的用途。然后在第二阶段，当他们从商学院毕业时，我们要求他们为一只盒子尽可能多地想出创造性的用途。然后，你可以根据他们想出的用途数量对这些用途进行编码。但你也可以根据他们想出的不同类别数量对它们进行编码。比如对于砖头，有人可能会说，哦，它可以用来当家具。所以这是一个类别。或者它可以被用作武器。
to generate as many creative uses as they can for a brick. And then at time two, when they graduated from business school, we asked them to think about as many creative uses they could for a box. And then you can code these uses for the number of uses they come up with. But you can also code them for the number of different categories they come up with. So for a brick, someone might say, oh, it could be used as a piece of furniture. So that's one category. Or it could be used as the weapon.
你可以把它扔向某人。那是另一个类别。或者它可以被用作家具，所以这是一个类别；或者它可以被用作武器，你可以把它扔向某人，那是另一个类别；或者它可以被用作房子的一个部分，那是另一个类别。同样，产生大量的好点子是大脑富有创造力的标志。亚当和他的同事们发现，在每一个这样的测试中，被随机选中去反思与异国人士约会经历的志愿者群体，其表现都优于那些被要求反思与同胞约会经历的人。他们的想法变得更加灵活、更新颖，基本上在我们最终的数据中，我们做的是构建了一个单一的综合创造力得分，它实际上涵盖了所有这些，但同样的效果实际上在每个
You could throw it at someone. That's another category. Or it could be used as a piece of furniture, so that's one category, or it could be used as the weapon, you could throw it at someone, that's another category, or it could be used as part of a house, that's another category. Again, generating lots of good ideas is a sign of a creative brain. What Adam and his colleagues found is that in every one of these tests, the group of volunteers randomly selected to reflect on their experience dating someone from another country, outperformed those asked to reflect on their experience dating someone from their own country. They increased in their flexibility and novelty of their ideas and basically in our final data what we did is we basically created a single composite creativity score which really collapsed across all these but the same effect actually emerges on each
单独的问题上都会出现，这表明这一效应是多么强劲和强大。尽管这些发现令人兴奋，但研究人员还是想知道它们在现实世界中是否经得起考验。他们正琢磨着该怎么做时，有一天，亚当去听了他的同事丹·王（Dan Wong）的一个演讲。在这里，他展示了一个非常棒、令人惊叹的数据集，涵盖了所有持有J1签证访问美国的人，并且他能够对他们进行调查。J1签证允许人们在限定时间内在美国工作，通常
of the individual problems which shows how robust and powerful the effect was. As exciting as the findings were the researchers wanted to know if they would hold up in the real world. They were wondering how to do that when one day Adam went to a presentation given by his colleague Dan Wong. And here's presenting this great amazing data set of everyone who had a J1 visa to visit the US and he was able to survey them. J1 visas allow people to work in the United States for a defined period of time, usually
在三个月到两年之间。在任何特定时间，大约有30万名J1签证持有者。演讲结束后，亚当走到丹面前，问他是否碰巧有关于跨文化接触及其联系深度的任何数据。他说：“我想我有的。”事实证明，丹曾向以前的J1签证持有者提出过这样一个问题：请汇报自从你回到祖国以来，你与美国朋友保持联系的频率。
between three months and two years. At any given time, there are about 300,000 J1 visa holders. After the talk, Adam went up to Dan and asked him, if by any chance, he had any data on cross-cultural contact and the depth of those connections. He said, I think I do. It turned out, Dan had asked former J1 visa holders this question, Please report the frequency of contact that you have with your American friends since you have returned to your home country.
该调查还询问了前签证持有者自回国以来一直在从事什么样的工作。亚当请丹查看他的数据，看看那些与美国朋友保持最密切联系的人与他们回国后是否成为企业家并创立了自己的公司之间是否存在相关性，以及他们回国后是否在公司里创造了新的管理实践。确实存在。他说：“哦，天哪，数据完全如你所预测的那样。”
The survey also asked the former visa holders, what kind of work they'd been doing since returning home. Adam asked Dan to take a look at his data and see if there was a correlation between those who'd maintained the closest contact with their American friends and whether they became an entrepreneur when they got home and founded their own company and whether they had created new practices in their company when they got home. Indeed there was. He said, oh my god, the data are exactly as you would have predicted.
所以这真的是这篇论文的锦上添花。你知道，我们已经有了来自实验室纸笔创造力测量的极好数据，但现在我们有了假说的核心——跨文化关系的深度、他们接触的频率能够预测这些现实世界的、具有重大意义的创造力指标，即他们成为企业家并创业的可能性，以及他们在自己的公司中改变、转型和创新的程度。这一次，亚当和他的同事没有被抢先。他们成功发表了。亚当说，他看到创造力与文化多样性之间的联系越来越多。在他最喜欢的项目之一中，他研究了主要时装屋在21个季度里推出的时装系列。
And so that was really the icing on the cake of this paper. You know, we'd already had this great data from laboratory-based paper and pencil creativity measures, but now we have the core of our hypothesis that the depth of intercultural relationships, the frequency which they had contact predicts these real world, consequential creativity measures, the probability that they became an entrepreneur and started their own business and how much they changed and transformed and innovated in their own This time, Adam and his colleagues did not get scooped. They got published. Adam says he sees more and more links between creativity and cultural diversity. In one of his favorite projects, he looked at fashion lines presented by major fashion houses over 21 seasons.
米兰、巴黎、伦敦和纽约。他发现，创造力与时装设计师沉浸于不同文化中的时间之间似乎存在着某种联系。创意总监在海外工作的时间长短预示着他们整个时装系列的创造力，但他们在海外工作过的国家数量则不然。后者产生的影响远不及他们在海外工作的时间长短。所有这些例子——时装设计师、商学院学生、音乐家——都有一个共同的主线。
Milan, Paris, London, and York. He found that there appeared to be a connection between creativity and the time that fashion creators had spent immersed in a different culture. The amount of time that the creative director had worked abroad predicted their entire fashion line creativity, but not the number of countries that they worked abroad. That didn't have near as much of an impact as the amount of time that they worked abroad. All these examples, the fashion designers, the business school students, the musicians, have a common thread.
所有这些跨文化关系都有深度。深入理解和学习另一种文化总有一种变革性的力量。我们可以从海外生活中学到这一点。我们可以通过与另一种文化背景的人约会来获得这一点。我们甚至可以通过旅行来获得这一点，但前提是我们真的去了解、理解、拥抱并适应了我们在海外旅行时接触到的那种文化。因此，我认为一个非常强有力的重大科学结论是：真正、深刻地理解另一种文化是增强你自己创造力的关键。亚当·吉林斯基和他的妻子珍说，他们希望他们的孩子以这种广阔的视角看待世界
All these cross-cultural relationships have depth. There's something about deeply understanding and learning about another culture that's transformative. We can get that from living abroad. We can get that from dating someone from another culture. We could even get it from traveling, but only if we really learned it understood and embraced and adapted to that other culture why we were traveling abroad. And so I think the big scientific conclusion that is very robust is that it's about really, truly, deeply understanding another culture is the key to enhancing your own creativity. Adam Galinsky and his wife, Jen, say they want their children to see the world
。亚当说，他的研究的美妙之处在于，它表明广泛合作的好处触手可得，尤其是在美国。你不必出国就能获得这种跨文化接触带来的部分创造力收益。你可以在美国通过拥抱、接触来自其他文化的人获得同样的益处。但话说回来，这里有个问题。它不能只是表面的。你必须与来自其他文化的人建立更深层次的联系，才能获得这种变革性的影响和体验。
in this expansive way. And Adam says, the beauty of his research is that it suggests the benefits of broad collaboration are within easy reach, especially in the United States. You don't have to go abroad to get some of the creativity benefits of having that intercultural contact. You can get that same benefit here in the United States by embracing engaging with people from other cultures. But again, there's the catch. It can't just be superficial. You've got to more deeply connect to people from other cultures to have that transformational impact in that experience.
你可以争辩说，我们今天讨论的一些例子存在局限性。与多元化团队合作的科学家或与来自其他传统的表演者组队的音乐家，这些人可能只是喜欢冒险的人。换句话说，让你变得更有创造力的不是音乐合作，而仅仅是拥有开放的心态。用科学的方法探讨这样的问题是非常困难的。我们无法进行实验来决定人们与谁约会或科学家应与谁合作。但我认为，即便在那些无法证明因果关系的研究所里，你依然可以看到多元化对创造力的影响。
You could argue there are limitations in some of the examples we've discussed today. It's possible that scientists who collaborate with diverse teams or musicians who team up with performers from other traditions, these people might just be risk-takers. In other words, it's not the musical collaborations that make you more creative, it's just having an open outlook. It's very difficult to explore questions like this scientifically. We can't conduct experiments where we dictate who people date or who scientists should collaborate with. But I would argue that even in studies where you cannot prove cause and effect, you can still see the influence that diversity has on creativity.
这不仅在个人层面上是真实的，在社群甚至国家层面上也是如此。以美国为例，从汽车、飞机到iPhone和谷歌，美国的创造力有力地塑造了我们的世界。这种非凡的独创性是否与美国非凡的多元化、几个世纪以来来到这里的移民潮有关呢？我倾向于认为答案是肯定的。在某些情况下，让一个群体倾听另一个群体的观点可能会很困难，甚至很危险。稍后回来，我们将听到当人们试图理解他们的敌人时会发生什么。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。一旦你听说阿夫纳·维亚里亚胡（Avnark Vyaryahu）的成长经历，你就很难想象他除了加入以色列军队之外还会做别的事。我在一个宗教家庭中长大，
And this is true, not just at the level of individuals, it's true at the level of communities, even nations. Consider for example, the United States, from the motor car and the airplane to the iPhone and Google, American creativity has powerfully shaped our world. Could some of this outsized ingenuity have to do with the extraordinary diversity of America, the waves of immigrants who arrived here over the centuries? I'd like to think the answer is yes. There are situations where it can be difficult, even dangerous, to get one group to hear
我们称之为宗教民族主义家庭。我的名字是以一名在1973年赎罪日战争中阵亡的士兵命名的。我父亲本人是一名伞兵。我哥哥是一名作战士兵。我周围的人、我的导师、我的老师、我的辅导员以及我所在的青年运动的成员，当然全都在军队里。所以我真的在等待机会去保罗卫国并服役。这算是我一直都知道自己会做的事，并且我想要
the perspective of another. When we come back, we hear what happens when people try to understand their enemies. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Once you hear about Avnark Vyaryahu's upbringing, it's hard to imagine him doing anything other than joining the Israeli military. I grew up in a religious family,
在这方面做到最好。但在他军旅生涯的早期，阿夫纳开始看到一些挑战他世界观的事情。他经常被要求执行一项被称为“稻草寡妇”（straw widow）的战术行动。这涉及进入巴勒斯坦人的家中，利用高楼层的窗户来掩护在街道上执行行动的其他以色列士兵。因此，在我的服役期间，我在无数次行动中发现自己闯入了人们的家中。
what we call religious nationalist family. I'm named after a soldier who was killed in 1973 in the Yom Kippur War. My dad, himself, was a paratrooper. My older brother was a combat soldier. The people around me, my mentors, my teachers, my counselors, and my youth movement were all, of course, in the military. So I was really waiting for my chance to go and protect my country and serve. That was sort of something that I always knew I would do and I wanted to be
我们称之为宗教民族主义家庭。我的名字是一个在1973年赎罪日战争中阵亡的士兵的名字。我父亲本人是一名伞兵。我哥哥是一名战斗士兵。我周围的人、我的导师、我的老师、我的辅导员以及我的青年运动成员，当然也都在军队里。所以我真的很期待有机会去保卫我的国家并服役。这基本上是我一直都知道自己会做并且想要做的事情
the best I could be at that. But early in his military service, Afnars started to see things that challenged his worldview. He was often asked to pull a maneuver known as a straw widow. This involved entering a Palestinian home to use the windows on the upper floors to cover other Israeli soldiers carrying out operations on the street. So I found myself numerous cases throughout my service invading people's homes in the
并为此做到最好。但在他服役的早期，阿夫纳斯开始看到一些挑战他世界观的事物。他经常被要求执行一种被称为“稻草寡妇”的战术。这涉及进入巴勒斯坦人的家，利用楼上窗户为在街上执行任务的其他以色列士兵提供掩护。因此我在服役期间的许多情况下发现自己闯入了人们的家中
middle of the night, most of the time, after we knew that the people inside these homes were innocent. Because you do not want to enter someone's house if you know that he's involved in some terrorist organization. Now this house, from that moment on, belongs to the soldiers, right? If the family wants to use the bathroom or the kitchen, in many cases they need permission from the soldiers, of course the family can't leave their house and this dynamic between soldiers and Palestinians was something that I was part of for many, many nights. And I think that that's where I really learned
通常在深夜，在我们确认这些住宅里的人是无辜之后。因为如果你知道某人卷入了某个恐怖组织，你是不想进入他家里的。从那一刻起，这栋房子就属于士兵了，对吗？如果家人想用洗浴室或厨房，在很多情况下他们需要得到士兵的许可，当然，这家人不能离开他们的房屋，而这种士兵与巴勒斯坦人之间的动态关系是我经历了许许多多个夜晚的事情。我想这就是我真正了解
for the first time, first of all, a little bit about the Palestinians because I was never in a Palestinian home before I started my service. I had no real contacts with Palestinians before I started my service But also I learned about the power dynamic that I was part of Just the fact that I was born sort of in the right side of the green line Just the fact that I was born to an Israeli Jewish family gave me the power To walk in with a helmet with a gun with my uniform and I was in control of an entire family. One night in particular stands out in his memory. He and other soldiers were supposed to take over a house. He thinks they may have made
初次体验的地方，首先，我对巴勒斯坦人有了一点了解，因为在我开始服役之前，我从未去过巴勒斯坦人的家里。在我开始服役之前，我与巴勒斯坦人没有真正的接触，但我也了解了我所身处其中的权力动态。仅仅因为我出生在绿线的正确一侧，仅仅因为我出生在一个以色列犹太人家庭，我就拥有了戴着头盔、拿着枪、穿着制服走进并控制一整家人的权力。有一个特定的夜晚在他的记忆中格外清晰。他和别的士兵本该接管一栋房子。他认为他们可能制造了
too much noise. We started hearing screaming from inside the Palestinian home. Our soldiers went up to the window where we hear the screams because, you know, we could be detected and that's not something we want. And we break the glass of this house and we peer in with our rifles. We had flashlights on the barrels. And we see on the floor of this house
太大的噪音。我们开始听到巴勒斯坦住宅内部传来的尖叫声。我们的士兵走到窗前，因为我们听到了尖叫声，你知道，我们可能会被发现，这不是我们想要的。我们打破了这栋房子的玻璃，用步枪向内张望。我们在枪管上绑了手电筒。我们看到这栋房子的地板上
an elderly lady helpless. And she was on the floor. I don't know what exactly happened but maybe she heard us and she was petrified and she just fell off her bed. I remember looking to the other side of the room and I could see the end of the corridor, some people or voices and it was her family who were petrified to come and help her. And I remember standing there and telling myself, this is not what I thought I would be doing. This is definitely not promoting the security of my country,
有一位无助的老妇人。她倒在地上。我不知道具体发生了什么，但也许她听到了我们的声音，吓坏了，从床上摔了下来。我记得看着房间的另一头，我能看到走廊尽头有一些人或听到声音，那是她的家人，他们吓得不敢过来帮她。我记得自己站在那里，对自己说，这不是我想象中我要做的事。这绝对不是在促进我国家的安全，
or the security of my family. And I started thinking, what about the family of this old lady? I mean, what do they think about me now? Moments like this are what prompted Avanair to start working with an organization called Breaking the Silence, a group of military veterans who want to talk openly about what they've learned. From Avanair's perspective,
或者我家人的安全。我开始思考，这位老妇人的家人呢？我的意思是，他们现在怎么看我？像这样的时刻促使阿夫纳（Avner）开始与一个名为“打破沉默”（Breaking the Silence）的组织合作，这是一个由希望公开谈论他们所学所知的退伍军人组成的团体。从阿夫纳的角度来看，
there's nothing on patriotic about Israeli veterans telling their stories, talking about moments they struggle with or Palestinian families they got to know. But others see it differently. Some see it as treason. In one video, a group targeting Avnare shows a Palestinian attacking in Israel with a knife. The video then accuses four human rights activists, including Avner, of protecting the terrorist.
以色列退伍军人讲述他们的故事、谈论他们挣扎的时刻或他们结识的巴勒斯坦家庭，这并没有什么不爱国的地方。但其他人有不同的看法。有些人认为这是叛国。在一段视频中，一个针对阿夫纳的组织展示了一名巴勒斯坦人用刀袭击以色列人的画面。然后视频指责包括阿夫纳在内的四名人权活动人士是在保护恐怖分子。
They called all four of us Stoulim, which basically means implanted, meaning my opinions, my thoughts, and the actions of myself and my friends are not things we actually think on our own, but we're actually working for in government. To us it sounded like they're blaming us for being spies. As I was listening to Avnare, I couldn't stop thinking about a study I read many years ago. Psychologist Lee Ross ran an experiment at Stanford University. He brought in students from a pro-Israeli group and a pro-Arab group and had them watch television news clips about the Arab-Israeli conflict. He found the pro-Israeli students saw lots of anti-Israel references in the news clips,
他们把我们四个人都叫做Stoulim，这基本上意味着被植入者，意思是我的观点、我的想法以及我和朋友们的行动并不是我们自己真正想出来的，而是我们在为政府工作。在我们听来，这就像是在指责我们是间谍。当我听阿夫纳讲述时，我禁不住想起多年前我读过的一项研究。心理学家李·罗斯（Lee Ross）在斯坦福大学做了一个实验。他找来了亲以色列和亲阿拉伯团体的学生，让他们观看有关阿以冲突的电视新闻片段。他发现，亲以色列的学生在新闻片段中看到了很多反以色列的暗示，
whereas the pro-Arab students saw lots of anti-Arab references while looking at the very same news clips. When Arabs in Israelis think about their conflict, each group desperately wants observers to know that they have been wronged. To acknowledge the pain on the other side is to somehow limit this claim. That's why two groups can look at the same reality and see completely different things. I told Avner, his story reminded me of the study. As you're telling me the story I'm realizing that one of the psychological implications of
而亲阿拉伯的学生在观看同一新闻片段时，则看到了很多反阿拉伯的暗示。当阿拉伯人和以色列人思考他们的冲突时，每个群体都极其希望旁观者知道他们受到了不公对待。承认另一方的痛苦，在某种程度上就是对这种主张的限制。这就是为什么两个群体可以看着同一现实却看到完全不同的事物。我告诉阿夫纳，他的故事让我想起了那项研究。当你在向我讲述这个故事时，我意识到
your work is that really when you try and empathize with what the other side is going through, there is something about that action that drives your friends and comrades really angry. That the idea that one of you would empathize with the other side feels like betrayal. Yeah, I think that you're touching a point which is true and I think is extremely difficult. You know, silence is not an Israeli disease, it's not an Israeli epidemic.
你的工作的心理学影响之一是，当你真正尝试去共情另一方正在经历的事情时，这种行为会引起你的朋友和战友们的极度愤怒。你们中的某个人去共情另一方，这种想法被认为是一种背叛。是的，我认为你触及到了一个真实且极其困难的点。你知道，沉默不是以色列的疾病，也不是以色列的流行病。
There is no society, there is no community, that does not live with this disease of silence. A big part of what breaking the silence and saying is, you know, the fact that we are talking about our actions, of course it doesn't mean there's no responsibility in the Palestinian side, but you know, when I do think about what can create change, and who has the power for change, I can't ignore the fact that in this specific point, we are the ones with the power.
没有任何一个社会、没有任何一个社区，能够摆脱这种沉默的疾病。“打破沉默”组织所表达的很大一部分内容是，你知道，我们谈论我们的行为这一事实，当然并不意味着巴勒斯坦方面就没有责任，但是，当我思考究竟是什么能够创造改变，以及谁拥有变革的力量时，我无法忽视这样一个事实：在这一点上，我们才是拥有权力的人。
Like Aufner, Muhammad Dejani started to develop empathy for his enemies when he ended up in the same room as them. Muhammad said he was forced into exile from his native Jerusalem because of his political work on Palestinian statehood. He was allowed to return in 1993 because his father was very sick. In the beginning it was very difficult for me to adjust, but my father, what cancer, started taking me to a incarium hospital where he used to have chemotherapy, and it made me observe my
和奥夫纳（Aufner）一样，穆罕默德·达贾尼（Muhammad Dajani）在与敌人共处一室时，也开始对敌人产生共情。穆罕默德说，由于他在巴勒斯坦建国问题上的政治工作，他被迫流亡离开他的故乡耶路撒冷。他于1993年获准返回，因为他的父亲病得很重。起初我很难适应，但我的父亲得了癌症，开始带我去因卡里姆医院，他在那里接受化疗，这让我得以观察我的
enemy, the Israelis, the doctors, the nurses, the staff, I noticed that their attitude to my father was not an attitude of an enemy to his enemy, but rather a doctor to his patient. Another time, Muhammad's mother suffered a heart attack. He was in a car with her, his brother was driving. We were coming to the Mingorian airport exit exit and my brother decided to take that exit. Muhammad told his brother he was being foolish. Israeli soldiers would stop them, harass them. Muhammad's brother said they had no choice.
敌人——以色列人、医生、护士和工作人员，我注意到他们对父亲的态度不是敌人对敌人的态度，而是医生对病人的态度。还有一次，穆罕默德的母亲心脏病发作。他和母亲坐在一辆车里，他哥哥在开车。我们来到明戈里安机场的出口，我哥哥决定走那个出口。穆罕默德告诉他哥哥，他这么做太愚蠢了。以色列士兵会拦住他们，骚扰他们。穆罕默德的哥哥说他们别无选择。
He pulled up at a security gate. When we came to the gates of the airport, and my brother told them that we have a sick woman with us and they saw her. They vacated one of the gates there and immediately called for ambulance there when the doctors came. They found out that they cannot move her, so they tried to restate her there, so it became like an operation room. These experiences changed Muhammad. He says he stopped thinking of the conflict
他把车开到了一个安全大门前。当我们来到机场大门时，我哥哥告诉他们我们车上有个病人，他们看到了她。他们腾出了其中的一个大门，并立即在那里叫了救护车，医生来了。他们发现无法移动她，于是尝试在那里对她进行心肺复苏，所以那里变得就像手术室一样。这些经历改变了穆罕默德。他说他不再以
in terms of Palestinians versus Israelis and started thinking in terms of the Palestinians and Israelis who were four peace and the Palestinians and Israelis who were against peace. And for the very first time he says he tried to see the Palestinian Israeli conflict from the Israeli point of view. He began teaching political science at Al-Quds University in Jerusalem, and he brought his new understanding with him. But his students couldn't relate. They hadn't had encounters with kind Israeli soldiers and carrying Jewish doctors. In order to come to the university, they used to go through many checkpoints, so they
巴勒斯坦人对阵以色列人的角度来思考冲突，而是开始从支持和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人以及反对和平的巴勒斯坦人和以色列人的角度来思考。他说，这是他破天荒第一次试图从以色列人的角度来看待巴以冲突。他开始在耶路撒冷的圣城大学（Al-Quds University）教授政治学，并带来了他全新的理解。但他的学生们无法产生共鸣。他们没有接触过善良的以色列士兵和慈爱的犹太医生。为了来到大学，他们必须通过许多检查站，所以他们
would leave something like three in the morning to get to the university at nine. Muhammad tried to get his students to see beyond the soldiers they met at checkpoints every day. The university set up an Israeli studies program and an American studies program, and he started to broach a topic most Palestinians had never encountered at school, the Holocaust. But Muhammad students, consumed as they were with their own trauma, could not or would not listen. One of his students was a young woman named Hanan.
通常在凌晨三点左右出发，以便九点到达大学。穆罕默德试图让他的学生们超越他们每天在检查站遇到的士兵。大学设立了以色列研究项目和美国研究项目，他开始触及大多数巴勒斯坦人在学校从未接触过的话题——大屠杀。但穆罕默德的学生们沉浸在自己的创伤之中，无法也不愿倾听。他的学生中有一个叫哈南（Hanan）的年轻女子。
And she was in Israeli presence for nine years. So to her, she looked at what happened with Jews, in Auschwitz, in Krakow, in different, uh, back and now, in different, uh, concentration camps, as if transmitting that to her own experience being a prisoner in Israeli jails and being discriminated against as a woman. Muhammad told Hananshi had constructed a prison inside her own mind, a prison that kept her from seeing the world, from the point of view of her enemy. When nothing worked with the students, Muhammad decided he would take Hanan and a couple dozen other students on a field trip to Europe.
她在以色列监狱里待了九年。因此，在她看来，她把犹太人在奥斯威辛、克拉科夫、在不同的、回到现在、在不同的集中营里发生的事情，等同于她自己作为囚犯在以色列监狱中以及作为女性受到歧视的经历。穆罕默德告诉哈南，她在自己的心灵深处建造了一座监狱，这座监狱阻碍她从敌人的角度去看世界。当对学生们的所有方法都不起作用时，穆罕默德决定带着哈南和其他几十名学生去欧洲进行一次实地考察。
They would visit Nazi concentration camps and learn, first hand, about the trauma at the heart of the Israeli Jewish experience. It was a scientific project to study about empathy, about if you learn about the suffering of the other, would that help more in your attitude for reconciliation? We decided to take these 30 Palestinian students, Auschwitz and Krakow in Poland. Almost immediately, there was trouble. So I received an email from the President of the University. He said that I heard rumors that you are taking students to Auschwitz and I would like you to make it very clear to them that the University has nothing to do with this trip.
他们将参观纳粹集中营，亲身体验以色列犹太人经历核心的创伤。这是一个研究共情科学项目，探讨如果你了解了他方的苦难，这是否会有助于改善你对实现和解的态度？我们决定带这30名巴勒斯坦学生前往波兰的奥斯威辛和克拉科夫。麻烦几乎立刻就找上门来。我收到了大学校长的一封电子邮件。他说，我听说有传言说你要带学生去奥斯威辛，我希望你向他们明确表示，大学与这次旅行没有任何关系。
Another student came to me and said, you should cancel this trip and that if you would go, once you come back, you might be facing a very big threat. Muhammad did not waver. He was an educator. And like Avner, he believed he was being a patriot. Empathy, he had come to believe, was the only way to understanding and to peace. When they got to Auschwitz, Muhammad and Hanan stopped at the entrance to the cap.
另一个学生来找我说，你应该取消这次旅行，如果你去了，等你回来，你可能会面临巨大的威胁。穆罕默德没有动摇。他是一位教育工作者。和阿夫纳一样，他坚信自己是一个爱国者。他渐渐相信，共情是通往理解和和平的唯一途径。当他们到达奥斯威辛时，穆罕默德和哈南在集中营入口处停了下来。
There was like a blackout saying, Arbite Machtfrey works at Sufri. So she was very surprised with that slogan at the gate of the Auschwitz camp and asked me about it and I said, why don't you look it up. Hanan learned the meaning of the cynical phrase. The Jewish prisoners who entered this camp were not set free by work. They were worked to death or killed. There was this big room which had toilets and we were told that every morning more than 2,000 people gathered in front of the room and then they are given ten seconds to use it and then
那里有一个黑色的牌子，上面写着“劳动带来自由”（Arbeit macht frei）。她对奥斯威辛集中营大门上的这个标语感到非常惊讶，并向我询问，我说，你为什么不查一下呢。哈南了解了这个讽刺短语的含义。进入这个集中营的犹太人并没有通过劳作获得自由。他们是被劳累致死或被杀害的。这里有一个很大的房间，里面有厕所，我们被告知每天早上有2000多人聚集在房间前面，然后他们只有十秒钟的时间使用它，接着
they have to leave. And so it was such a humiliation for the individual. They were things they never heard of in terms of how human beings were humiliated and broken. As they walked through the camp, Muhammad noticed that Hanan and the other students were no longer seeing the Holocaust through the lens of their own suffering. They were actually empathizing with Jews, their enemies. It was very emotional to them,
他们就必须离开。这对个人来说是极大的羞辱。这些是他们从未听说过的事情，关于人类是如何被羞辱和摧毁的。当他们穿过集中营时，穆罕默德注意到哈南和其他学生不再透过他们自身苦难的有色眼镜来看待大屠杀。他们实际上是在与犹太人——他们的敌人产生共情。这让他们情绪激荡，
one of the, and some of the, some of the girls even cried. One of the students was telling me, I thought that Hitler gathered the Jews in these concentration camps to send them to Palestine, to have them shipped to Palestine. And they had total misconception about what is the Holocaust, what is the concentration camp, what did it mean, how life was there, so it was an open door for them. But back at home, Mohamed's colleagues at the university did not see the trip as an invaluable
其中的一些女孩甚至哭了。其中一个学生告诉我，我以为希特勒把犹太人聚集在这些集中营里是为了把他们送到巴勒斯坦，把他们运送到巴勒斯坦。他们对什么是大屠杀、什么是集中营、它意味着什么、那里的生活是怎样的，有着完全错误的认识，所以这是一扇为他们打开的大门。但在家里，穆罕默德在大学里的同事们并不认为这次旅行是一次无价的
educational experience. The last day in Auschwitz, my secretary wrote to me an email saying that students have come and the RANS Act or office, they are making demonstrations against you on campus, and that they came and left you a letter threatening your life that you should not come back to the university and that if you come back they are going to tell you and the letter is with me and she said that there is a lot of enmity and an uproar on campus regarding the trip. So that prepared me that the reception will not be easy going back to the university. And once I went there, I noticed that there was a lot of enmity people who were looking at me as a matrator, of betrayed them.
教育经历。在奥斯威辛的最后一天，我的秘书给我写了一封电子邮件，说学生们来了，学生事务办公室正在校园里针对你举行示威活动，他们来并留下了一封威胁你生命的信，说你不应该回到大学，如果你回来，他们就要对你不利，信在我这里，她说校园里关于这次旅行有很多敌意和骚乱。这让我有了心理准备，回到大学后，接待工作不会轻松。一旦我去了那里，我注意到有很多敌意，人们把我视为叛徒，背叛了他们。
At the same time, nine student organizations issued a statement on campus saying that this is normalization and normalization equals treason. Muhammad was forced to resign from his job. One night someone set fire to his car. He knew his life was in danger. He packed his bags and left Jerusalem again. This time exiled by his fellow Palestinians. I asked him how it felt to be called a traitor.
与此同时，九个学生组织在校园发表声明称，这是关系正常化，而正常化等于叛国。穆罕默德被迫辞职。一天晚上，有人放火烧了他的车。他知道自己的生命处于危险之中。他收拾好行李，再次离开耶路撒冷。这一次，他被同胞巴勒斯坦人驱逐流放。我问他被称为叛国者是什么感觉。
What was most hurtful for me, most painful, was nobody stood by me. That was really what was most painful for me. Also the fact that I have dedicated all my life for the Palestinian cause, and suddenly I'm a traitor for that cause, so that also was painful. When I first talked to Muhammad, he was living in the United States. So was Avner.
对我来说最受伤害、最痛苦的是，没有人站在我这边。这真的是对我和最痛苦的事情。还有这样一个事实，我把毕生精力都奉献给了巴勒斯坦事业，而突然之间我成了这项事业的叛徒，所以这也令人痛苦。当我第一次与穆罕默德交谈时，他住在美国。阿夫纳也是。
In the years since I interviewed them, they have both managed to return home. The psychologist Michael Wall and Nyla Brandscom once asked Jewish volunteers to think about the suffering of Palestinians. The psychologist reminded some of the volunteers about the Holocaust. Compared to others, Jews reminded of their own group suffering showed less compassion
在我采访他们之后的几年里，他们都设法回到了家乡。心理学家迈克尔·沃尔（Michael Wohl）和尼拉·布兰兹科姆（Nyla Branscombe）曾要求犹太志愿者思考巴勒斯坦人的苦难。心理学家提醒部分志愿者注意大屠杀。与其他志愿者相比，被勾起对自身群体苦难回忆的犹太人表现出的同情心更少
toward Palestinian suffering. The same thing happens with other groups. Americans reminded of traumas, even distant traumas like the Pearl Harbor attack, show less empathy for victims of torture carried out by American service members. Trauma creates justifications for the harm we inflict on other groups. It makes us turn inward. Empathy demands that we turn outward to open ourselves to understanding and to risk. Today's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Maggie Penman, Max Nestrak and
对于巴勒斯坦人的苦难。其他群体也会发生同样的事情。当美国人被唤起对创伤的记忆时，哪怕是像珍珠港袭击这样遥远的创伤，他们对遭受美军酷刑折磨的受害者的共情也会减少。创伤为我们对其他群体造成的伤害提供了正当理由。它让我们转向内向。共情则要求我们转向外向，敞开心扉去理解并承担风险。今天的节目由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕茨·沙阿（Parts Shah）、玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）制作，
Raina Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Thomas Liu, Laura Correll and Camilla Vargas Restrepo. For more hidden brain, you can follow the show on Facebook and Twitter. Please be sure to subscribe to our podcast. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
蕾娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作。节目由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）和卡米拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特波（Camilla Vargas Restrepo）。想了解更多“隐藏的大脑”，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注本节目。请务必订阅我们的播客。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。